un panorama desafiante en Brasil
tras asumir su cargo el nuevo presidente
brasileño asumirá diversos retos
principalmente ligados a la economía y
el medio ambiente temas claves en la
contienda electoral más polarizada de la
historia en familia en mi familia a todo
el mundo es bolsonarista todos yo vine a
escondida de mañana muy temprano para
hacer mi parte para la democracia a
favor de Lula
yo quiero que gane evolucionario por
todo lo que hizo en estos cuatro años de
gobierno creo que los próximos cuatro
años serán todavía mejores y también por
todo lo que hizo para los brasileños fue
completamente diferente de los gobiernos
anteriores
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales determina si la cuarta
democracia más grande del mundo se
mantiene con la extrema derecha del
presidente y candidato Yair bolsonaro o
si devuelve a la izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva al poder en medio de
grandes dificultades como las
consecuencias de la pandemia que aún
siguen latentes en el país
mientras Brasil atraviesa por una
inflación creciente con un 7.2%
registrado en septiembre los asuntos en
materia ambiental también han ganado
gran protagonismo en estas elecciones
principalmente por la explotación del
Amazonas según datos del Instituto
Nacional de pesquisas especiales Brasil
ha perdido 47.000 kilómetros cuadrados
de zonas verdes en la amazonía durante
la actual administración
desafíos de Gran importancia para el
segundo país más poblado de América y la
economía más fuerte de la región